Amen.
Amen. All right, you can be seated this morning.
It is a beautiful day. It's great to see you.
Uh, it's a beautiful day for many reasons actually.
We have a great weather, of course,
but it's also promotion Sunday.
That's what we call it around here when
everybody moves up a grade.
And so that means a couple things.
First, it means that there are kindergartners in the
room for the first time.
And so kindergartners, if you're here, let's just hear it.
Can you hear it? Kid? Kids, kids, kindergartners, anybody?
Are you all kindergartners? I, I said kindergartners.
Can I hear you? Anyway? Okay. Um, okay.
Some of you're like, man, I don't want to go back.
I love nap time. Alright, so, uh, we are gonna be
worshiping together.
We got new faces in the room.
And so that means just invite those around you.
Kindergarters, I know you're able to engage.
I've seen you do it. I'm excited to have you in here
with us every Sunday.
Uh, but also greet those around you.
Welcome each other as you see each other today.
Uh, there are a lot of new faces today and next week,
but it's also a great day
because what we're gonna do today is celebrate calling it
Celebration Sunday in a way
where we are utilizing our worship gathering to celebrate
specifically what God has done this summer.
And many of you don't get to see what all happens
through the ministries of our church.
You don't get to be at camp with us
or do things, uh, during the weeks.
You don't get to see it. Like some of us on staff get
to see a, a lot of that.
And so we wanna share just part of it with you, uh,
because it's, it's a meaningful thing.
Now, why would we do this? Why would we celebrate like this?
Why is celebrating important?
Well, here's what Psalm 77 11 says.
I will remember the deeds of the Lord.
Yes, I will remember your wonders of old.
And so we too need to be reminded of what God has done.
These wonders of old, what he's accomplished in us,
what he's accomplished through us.
Because then what that leads us to is
what we did when we came in here.
Psalm 100 verse four, enter his gates with Thanksgiving,
his courts with praise.
Give thanks to him and bless his name.
Like that's a command in Psalm 100 for us to do that
as we come into his presence, which we know we always are.
But in a way, this today uniquely as we gather like this is
that as well.
And so we do that because God's commanded it.
It's important for us.
But we also do this because God has, has baked celebration
into our very faith.
Like this is just part of what it means to be a Christian.
Think about the Old Testament.
God commanded feasts
and festivals for his people to celebrate.
And those weren't just parties that they got
to have great meals and time together.
Those were sacred remembrances that God ordained
for his people to participate in The Feast of the Harvest,
the Feast of Booths, the Passover,
there's many others you can go find in the Old Testament.
But each of those was, was a divine appointment
for God's people to stop, to remember,
and to celebrate God's faithfulness.
Think about the, the New Testament, the Lord's Supper
that we celebrate regularly here.
That is a reminder.
God instituted a celebration
to remind us of what Jesus has done.
Jesus literally said, remember Right.
And so these acts that God has put into our faith means
celebration is not optional for Christians.
These are commanded things for us.
Celebration is commanded. Just listen to Psalm 78.
This is verses four
and seven says, we will not hide them from their children,
but tell to the coming generation the glorious deeds
of the Lord and his might
and the wonders that he has done so
that they should set their hope in God
and not forget the works of God, but keep his commandments.
See, when we celebrate what God has done,
we're not just being grateful, as good as that is, as right
as that is, we're declaring his character
and we're strengthening our faith.
We are encouraging one another
and we're turning around to the next generations
and saying, here's who our God is passing the faith on
to those behind us.
And so that's part of why we celebrate.
There's one more celebration,
also builds our spiritual memory.
It builds our spiritual memory. Israel had feasts.
Israel had festivals,
but God also commanded them throughout the Old Testament
to build altars in the wilderness
at times throughout history as markers of his faithfulness.
And so every time Israel families, individuals would walk by
that pile of rocks in the wilderness, they would remember
that God was faithful here.
He will surely be faithful again. It was a reminder.
God was faithful. Look what he did here.
Remember how he walked us
through on dry land in the middle of the ocean, right?
He was faithful Here he'll surely be faithful again.
That's spiritual memories.
Celebrations do similar things for us even today.
So that's why we're doing this.
We're gratefully celebrating God
and we're asking him, do it again.
Do it again. God, we can't control that.
We don't manipulate him, but we're asking him in
faith, God we know you.
Can you have, please do it again. Do more again.
And so we're gonna sing, we're gonna have stories,
we're gonna hear testimonies, all of
that today throughout this.
But let's stand first and let's sing those truths of
what he's done before we hear some stories.
Let's sing together what he's done.
Um, hi, my name is Cooper.
Um, this summer I got to attend both student camp
and, um, super summer and both were really great events.
But um, at super summer there's just this deeper
level of discussion.
Um, and there's something about being around a group
of people that you've never met
before, um, that you just get this picture
of heaven in my mind of being around hundreds of kids
and teenagers worshiping at the top of their lungs.
Getting To experience, seeing God move
through teens your age, um,
that live in your state is super encouraging.
Uh, especially when you know you're with people you do know
and building relationships with people you don't know.
Um, it's just a really encouraging feeling to get to be
around believers like that for a week.
Super summer and Kingdom of the Beach were definitely
highlights of my summer.
I think the most impactful, uh,
event this summer has been kids camp for me.
Uh, getting to use my gifts and serve on the worship team
and, uh, grow a relationship
with other kids in my free time and during rec.
'cause it's just been really special.
I went to A lot of the camps this summer
and I thought it was really cool just to see
how like at kids camp, the kids responding to the teachings
and just seeing them actively start to love one another.
There's something so special about looking out
as you're worshiping at a couple hundred kids,
praising the Lord with you, um, really speaks to
what childlike faith is.
Um, and I think that spoke to my heart, um,
and how that God can use people
of all ages to praise him and to glorify him.
I think our church this summer has grown a lot both in the
student ministry and as a whole.
Um, our reflection
and meditation on Romans 1212, um, I've seen a lot
of growth, especially in our student ministry,
just us coming together in prayer
and then as a church as a whole.
Um, I feel like our connectivity has been growing
and ever increasing, both in the student ministry
and in the adult ministries.
Uh, seeing our church take up opportunities
to serve in state, out of state
and even out of the country is super encouraging,
especially giving, um, people my age opportunity and adults
and families the opportunity to do that.
Uh, it's super, it's just super
heartwarming to see all that happen.
For me personally, the Lord has really been showing me how
he can work through even the loneliest times.
One of the hardest things to go through at this age is just
feeling like you're alone.
Which what God has taught me this summer is
that you're like, you're not 'cause He's with you.
Um, and I really, I've been convicted this summer
of just longing for a person,
but knowing that the Lord is the one I need
God. This summer at
the beginning I prayed for God
to just give me, uh, his wisdom
and direct me down his path for me
and to give me godly friends to help me do that.
And he's brought me closer to people this summer
that I never thought I'd be close with.
And they have absolutely changed my life.
Um, even in just these three months,
they've held me accountable
and they've been there for me every step of the way.
And that's exactly what I needed this summer.
Um, this year at student camp, we walked
through the Psalms of Ascent
and it was just kind of God reminding me that,
um, he is in control.
Psalms 1 27, 1 through two talks about, um,
if he's not the one building the house,
you will labor in vain.
I feel like God's been working in my heart
to grow my relationship closer with him
and, uh, seek out strong fellowship with other men
to walk their life together. God
Has really been challenging me to, instead
of just being filled up to pour out into the other students
and the younger classmen, um, and just the people around me.
Isn't that pretty amazing church? Yeah.
Got more stories to come,
but just, just a glimpse of what God has done, uh,
especially in our student ministry this summer,
but he's been writing his story
of faithfulness across our lives, across our church.
It's been amazing to watch.
I just think back to how I've seen God be faithful to many
of you through some really difficult seasons this summer.
Uh, I, I know of financial strain
that you've seen God provide in miraculous ways.
I think of broken relationships, how God has sustained you
through in the midst of that.
I can see dark seasons emotionally that God has brought you
through and, and you're still walking maybe in the darkness,
but you see a glimmer of light
because of what he's done in your life.
Uh, we've also watched faithful men
and women who've lived long, full
lives finally finish their race and see Jesus face to face.
Uh, it seems like this summer has been a lot of those,
and it's a beautiful grief.
There's a hope mixed together with the grief through loss,
but then to watch God work in
and through those who are remaining here grieving the loss,
for example, here's an encouraging story.
Uh, this lifted my soul so much just a couple days ago.
One of our senior saints lost his wife of 69 years
and he cared for her so well through the last few stages
of her life especially,
but all of her life, well, yesterday he was talking to one
of our staff members and he said, Hey Brad,
are you going to church tomorrow?
And Brad said, yes, of course I'm going to church.
And he says, me too, because I've gotta go
and thank God 100 times for how good he's been
to me and my sweet wife.
Like that's, that's only the Lord doing
that in a life, right?
Like that's the kind of stuff that we see God do
even quietly behind the scenes in places like that.
I, I look back as well, Cooper mentioned it in the video,
but I look back to this summer, the power of God's word.
As we walk through Romans 12, and God was realigning us back
and still is realigning us to Christ's perfect image,
how he worked through his word.
We've seen many new faces join our church family
in the last few months.
People who are seeking questioning, searching, longing for
healing as found only in the gospel of Jesus Christ
and the people committed to him.
Kids camp a few weeks ago has been mentioned.
We had five children share with some
of those leaders on the video that God was drawing them
to faith in the Lord as their savior
and as their king five children.
And then at the same camp, I, I sat around a table
with a group of third grade girls as they asked
and answered deep theological questions that they wanted
to know and understand our God, third grade girls.
And, and one girl asked a question
and this other girl answered it.
And then they looked to me
and I was like, that's how I would've answered it.
And that was great. And they were encouraging
to each other in that just this past Sunday we had a,
a young man come up after the service and,
and he was being prayed for by friends and family.
And in that moment, God led him to be born again
through the gospel of Jesus Christ,
right up here after the service.
Uh, we've seen so many this summer inviting friends
and family to gather with us for worship
because they're so excited.
You, you are so excited for what God is doing in your life
that you can't help but share it with people who are
around you and say, Hey, come
and see what God has done
then just watch our students worship
like there is a passion, their hunger for God's wor.
It's not just this emotional sense of like, Hey,
I love being in this environment.
There's an emotional depth of hunger
for God's word happening amongst our student ministry.
And so guys, listen, I know most of you're sitting here,
some over there, but I'm proud of you.
I really am. It's exciting to watch
and I'm super excited to see how he grows
that fueling the passion for us.
But it's not just them. I've said this
before many, many times
to hear you sing church that's growing.
It shows we've been talking about treasuring Christ the last
few months as a church.
There's an evidence that it's happening as we just say,
Jesus, you're worth it.
And I'm shouting your praise in song.
And we could go on and on like everybody,
we could have a parade of people just coming up here
and saying, here's what God did.
Here's what God did. We could do that.
But as great as all that is, let's not get the wrong idea.
We don't celebrate all this because we're lucky
because we worked really hard this summer or
because we have a great staff team and a lot of resources.
And look what we can produce.
We've seen what we've seen this summer
as evidence of a God who's always working, always loving,
always faithful, always good.
All the things that we talk about today,
everything we've said so far, he is always in that.
And if you ever doubt that, all you have to do is look back
to the cross of Jesus Christ.
If it looks like there's not much you can celebrate,
just keep looking back to the gospel
because that's the ultimate display of his love,
the sacrifice of his son to redeem us from sin so
that we could live in the freedom
of his presence both here and forever.
All because he loved his enemies like you and me.
And so if we're looking for it, there is
so much in our lives that we can celebrate God with.
There's so much we can give thanks for.
There's so much what we can say.
The psalmist in Psalm 1 26, verse three,
the Lord has done great things for us
and we are glad, but I don't have much.
No, you've got the cross. You've got what God did in that.
There's so much more if we really look through God's lenses,
let's not be ashamed to give him praise
for the things that we see.
We recognize his hand in our lives.
Let's give him praise for that.
Amen. Well, in the
second service today, uh,
at this point in the service, we have a baptism.
We, a young man, 19-year-old who, uh, came to faith
and just wanted to express that to the church today.
And so you can be praying for Dennis
as he gets baptized later.
Uh, but I, I just wanna pray for him and I
and I I think it's time
and appropriate to play, pray for all of our students,
kids, teachers, administrators, started school now and,
and just to see God work in major ways
through them this year.
And so let's pray together towards that end.
God, thank you for Dennis coming to be baptized today.
And we pray that you would encourage him and
and spur on his faith as he continues to follow you.
But in light of that, and in light of
what you've done this summer, we do pray God, that this
next year, especially the schools
or that you would fill with your spirit, your people to go
shine light in a dark place, to witness to
the wonders of God, the glory of the gospel, the goodness
of our savior, God, may you do a mighty work.
May it be something that only you can take the credit for,
that we all look back
and are stunned by to watch you do what you do this year.
Thank you God for what you have done.
And we pray for more, not for our own selfish reasons,
but for more glory for you.
In Jesus' name. Amen.
Well, as we celebrate what God has done,
we also prepare our hearts for what we believe he will do
that he goes, we go forward into God's purposes.
The same God who's been faithful this summer,
we believe will be faithful in seasons ahead.
This is not today just a a sentimental look backward.
This is a faith building launch forward.
When I think about transformative faith, I can't help
but think of Peter in Matthew chapter 14.
So the scene is where Jesus was walking on the water
and all the disciples are in the boat
and they're watching him do this and they're stunned
and they're amazed and all of those things.
Of course, yet, listen to what Peter said,
Matthew 1428.
And Peter answered him, Lord, if it is you
command me to come to you on the water.
Now we kind of skate right over that.
But that's faith, isn't it?
That's a wholehearted belief
that God could suspend his own created rules of physics,
that people can't walk on water.
You sink, right, that God created the
rules to work that way.
But he was already suspending it with Jesus.
He could do it for Peter too.
He believed that that was going to happen and God did.
But here's the thing. It took Peter
getting out of the boat in order to experience the joy
of walking on the water.
Now we know that he took his eyes off Jesus
and he started sinking and Jesus had to save him.
And that's part of it. But he had
to step outta the boat first to trust
that God was gonna do what he said he would do.
So here's the thing. I don't think God did all that he did
to save us, to keep us forever
as his children, as as saved ones,
just so that we would sit in these seats most Sundays
and be a little bit better morally than everybody else.
Like I don't think that's the extent
of his salvation in our lives, his work to bring about all
that he's done forever and ever.
I don't think that's it.
He saved us to walk in faith
and to follow Jesus wherever he leads us,
no matter the cost, no matter the
risk, he saved us.
Not just so that we could have some country club.
He saved us so that we could follow him.
And just think about what God did.
You're thinking, man, I'm just an average person.
Think about what God did
through average people all over the Bible.
Abraham left everything he knew to go
to a land he didn't know.
But all he knew was
that God promised him something when he went.
Or think about Moses confronting the most powerful man in
the entire world, Pharaoh, with a stick
and a promise from God.
Think about Esther risking her
life to save her people.
Or you think about David trusting God
in the face of a giant as everybody else ran
and hid. 'cause David had a promise.
David Knew a faithful God.
But don't think we often read the Bible this way.
Those people are not superheroes.
They're flawed humans just like you and I.
They just fully understood that they fully belong to God,
that their life was in his hands.
That that kind of belief that you say, God, I'm all yours.
That frees us to hold our lives pretty loosely.
Say, God, you're in charge of this.
I can do whatever I need to to follow you
because I trust you to hold my life loosely.
What does that even mean? It means you recognize
that you plans your career, your spouse, your children,
your comfort zone, your dreams are all God's gifts
for you to steward.
They're not your possessions to clutch.
This is God's gift of life
and everything in it for his glory,
for his purpose, for his kingdom.
Not for me to hold onto.
Not saying be reckless, be irresponsible.
I'm just saying be available. Just be available
saying God, okay, here's my life.
I'm all in. And here's the beautiful truth about this.
God is not asking you to come up with something new.
You're sitting here thinking, well, okay,
God wants me to follow him.
God, I don't have to create something out of nothing.
He's merely inviting you
and inviting me to join him in what he's already doing
and how he's already working.
Listen to what Jesus said, John five 17, he said,
my father is working until now and I am working.
He's already working. He's been working forever
and he's gonna be working forever forward.
He's active. God is active in our world right now.
He's doing things in the schools where our kids attend.
He's doing things in the workplaces that you go
to every day.
He's working in our neighborhoods.
He's working among the nations. He is stirring hearts.
He's opening minds. He's drawing hearts to himself.
So don't be intimidated.
You have to come up with something new.
Just recognize that he is moving, he's working,
and he's just inviting you to step into
that current that he's working.
It's the famous Henry Blackaby quote,
if you ever did experience in God, you know this.
Find where God is at work and join him in it.
Just look around. What is God doing?
Be prayerfully observant
and join him in it could mean all kinds of things.
Having a conversation with a coworker who just happened
to tell you that they're having a difficult time in their
life right now, and they're the ones
that, that you're the one that came to.
Do you think that's an accident?
That's God working in their life, inviting you
to step into the current with
them Serving here.
We have ministries going all the time.
You don't have to create something.
You just say, what can I do?
Or a local ministry that's serving our community.
You just step into the current with them.
They're already doing it. Don't create something.
Just join what God is doing. You have professional skills.
There's a need in our community that needs
that professional skill.
Go meet the need. Like don't create.
You don't have to create something.
Just go follow what God is doing.
Or think about this somebody in your life
or a group of people in your life who are skeptical
or cynical about Christianity and you just show up in love
and compassion over and over and over again.
God's doing something in their life
and they're talking about the faith and you just show up
and you just be consistent.
You don't have to have all the answers,
but you can be a person that they trust.
See, it's just in joining in with God and what he's doing.
Be prayerfully observant
and be ready to move when you sense his spirit leading
you somewhere.
Because here's the goal, a year from now, we look ahead.
Let's say we're gonna do a celebration Sunday, August 15th,
16th, next year.
What's our goal between now and then?
What's, what does it look like?
Well, listen, our goal is not just a bigger church
or a better celebration Sunday.
We got more stories, we all kinds of stuff.
A bigger banner out there. Like what?
No, that's not the goal here.
The goal is what Jesus said in Matthew five 14 through 16.
Jesus said, you are the light of the world.
A city set on a hill cannot be hidden,
nor do people light a lamp and put it under a basket,
but they put it on a stand
and it gives light to all in the house.
In the same way, let your light shine
before others so that they may see your good works
and give glory to your father who is in heaven.
That's the goal. And he talked about light and darkness.
Think about light. Light doesn't have to work hard
to push out the darkness.
It just has to shine.
And Jesus said it must be visible in order
to make a difference.
Listen, church, our world is hungry
for authentic light.
They've tried and seen too many shallow solutions,
too much empty hope that there's a need,
a hunger for something real, for a light that shines,
that can stand up to their pain
and still offer genuine love and hope through it.
Something that's going
to actually make a difference in their life.
That's the kind light that we carry,
that God has put in us as believers.
They're looking for something.
We have what they are looking for.
And it's not to give us glory, as Jesus said, it's
to glorify our Father who's in heaven.
And so that's good news.
But let's not forget something here.
Let's not forget there's an enemy that we have as well.
And that enemy of our souls is not afraid
of our programs, of our building, building, of the fact
that a few hundred of us gather in here every Sunday.
He doesn't care about that at all.
What he's terrified of is a group of people whose lives are
so transformed by the gospel that they're willing
to go obey their savior and Lord in anything they do.
He's terrified of transformed lives
by the gospel of Jesus Christ.
He knows he can't win.
He knows he can't do anything against it.
He's terrified of people who are so secure in their, their,
their security, their faith, their future in Christ.
They're so secure that they live with this prayerful hope
that they're risking their bold in their faith.
He's terrified of that
because he knows that is what defeats him.
Again, Jesus did not die on the cross so that we could live
cautious self-protecting lives.
He died so that we could live with the kind of freedom
that comes from knowing our ultimate security is found in
him, not in our circumstances.
He died so we could love people like he loved us,
which is costly and risky.
And so in light of all of this today, be prayerful.
Be available. Open your hands.
Be willing to be uncomfortable and just take the next step
because there's nothing better than watching God use your
life to impact somebody else.
It's not about comfort and convenience and preference
and getting what you want.
It's about watching the God of the universe choose
to use you in somebody else.
It is unbelievable
and it's joy filling, life giving to participate in that.
And remember, he's faithful,
so you can follow him wherever he leads
you without any fear.
But it's gonna cost. It's gonna be risky.
You can follow him because he's faithful.
He's done it before. He's gonna do it again.
I want you to see this video.